yes I was gonna scare you and then they
sincerely started to fall asleep as
close you can take the camera away from
the girl
can't take the gas out of the girl til
it naturally comes out hi guys um it is
Thursday here on its grace and it should
be a tipsy Thursday however I'm in Vegas
right now and feeling a bunch of stuff
on this camera and I put a card into
this camera it's a small card and I
didn't bring a converter to put the card
into my computer so we're going to wait
one more day for all this footage oh
just add a panel here at the reason
we're here is for NAB NAB Convention
National Association of Broadcasters
nearly aborted babies no whoa absolutely
opposite of that we are all born all of
us here cool I'm in a bed right now
because we came back from our paddle and
I just fell asleep I'm so tired
hey Deano there's so many things I
should be doing
oh that's Brad Garrett I thought it was
sitting on side table and I thought it
was David Copperfield um it's not it's
Brad gay son of magician it's a comedian
eggs on my face and turn them into dumps
guys sorry that this is just a video
like this I'm just a floating golf head
right now but tomorrow we'll get back to
normal you guys are doing it right no no